berlin
ich will dass sie nicht
weimar in thüringen ist keine große
stadt aber eine stadt mit großer
geschichte weimar steht für goethe
schiller die kunstrichtung bauhaus die
gründung der ersten deutschen republik
wobei der dichter und denker johann
wolfgang von goethe am bekanntesten ist
unsere drei kandidaten lernen heute ein
besonderes stück deutscher kultur kennen
die esskultur findet das rezept für
einen thüringischen zwiebelkuchen
herauskauft alle zutaten und backt diese
spezialität zwiebelkuchen ist man
natürlich nicht nur in thüringen
aber die thüringer sind sich sicher ihr
zwiebelkuchen ist der beste
ich mag an
mal sehen ob die drei die richtige
mischung finden kann man schön
abschmecken vorher muss richtig kräftig
ein moderner nicole und eric wollen das
rezept am liebsten schwarz auf weiß in
der touristeninformation finden sie eine
zutatenliste
das team hat sich entschieden nicht auf
dem markt sondern im supermarkt
einzukaufen
hier gibt es alle zutaten an einem ort
und es so schön zu wissen dass die
richtige preis nicht so steckt händels
dass du in der küche ihrer ferienwohnung
unterhalten sie sich über ihre eigenen
kochgewohnheiten eigentlich nicht jetzt
kochen alle drei gemeinsam und nicole
bereut es bald dass sie die zwiebeln
schneiden muss
also übernimmt eric diese arbeit
als nächstes werden die zwiebeln in
einer pfanne angebraten nicole kümmert
sich um den teig und dann fehlt noch die
sauce mit eiern und schmand alles
zusammen kommt in eine auflaufform und
anschließend in den backofen
der zwiebelkuchen ist fertig und duftet
aber jetzt kommt der entscheidende test
schmeckt den thüringern der
zwiebelkuchen sowie in team nord
gebacken hat
das ist ein liebling und es schmeckt
genauso wie in thüringen aufgabe
bestanden jetzt steht es 8 zu 6 für team
nord und der rest des zwiebelkuchen es
ist auch schnell verteilt
berlin
muss ich bilder ziehen